[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'll show you who's boss
yeah
all right clap
clap you stupid people
happy glorious thursday what an amazing
show we have for you today
dana parino is here
doesn't she look lovely
but wait is that really dana i mean it
could be or it could be a blood-sucking
demon but i guess you'll have to trust
me that it's dana fact is you can't tell
because like the reoccurring zit on my
neck it's covered up maybe it's dana
maybe it isn't we'll have to see if she
tests positive for sugar and spice
you see i'm being the opposite of
transparent to remind you of our current
government have you noticed that
everything they do these days that turns
out bad illegal or just infuriating
always begins with a cover-up whether
you were the victim of your boss's
unwanted advances at your job in albany
or had relatives die in a new york
nursing home because of horrible
decisions your suspicions are either
denied or mocked by the people in power
you might even be called a stupid son of
a [ __ ] by a guy who completes sentences
as often as i dunk basketballs
the list of deliberate non-transparency
is endless as is my hate for it the
origins of wuhan well they mocked the
lab league theory even though the place
was breeding more disease than the
playboy mansion grotto gain of function
never happened well actually it did and
yeah it was funded by whom long story a
recurring character named anthony fauci
was involved
how about your risk of dying from covid
i bet you don't even know your specific
risk even after two and a half years
and what happened to the rapid testing
how about a rapid answer no chance it's
like asking a waitress where your drinks
are after 20 minutes in a crowded
restaurant yeah i know you'll find out
and circle back
did the supply chain ever get fixed hell
even the looters in la are complaining
that the trains are late
and where's mayor pete is he still
lactating
what's camella doing hell what's joe
even doing besides napping
so how are we dealing with china well
there's kovid fentanyl the uyghurs do we
know anything
what was in that letter to putin a stern
warning a mysterious white powder 30
bucks for a new shirt
what about crime remember when those
hate crime stats were everywhere then
they weren't remember when mug shots
mattered now they're gone then as
murders spiked bureaucrats combined
violent and non-violent crimes into a
lump sum to hide the rise in murder as
if people attacked on subway platforms
were thinking hey at least this isn't
mail fraud it's more sleight of hand
from the people who have blood on theirs
there's hunter's laptop of course
something so obviously real but buried
like a murder victim in a crawl space
and if you brought it up you were the
one who couldn't tweet
joe biden's business dealings harder to
find than a clean meth pipe in hunter's
car at 2am
and what was joe's entire election
strategy not being there a human
embodiment of opaqueness the less you
see of him the better because what you
see is what you get and what you get
stinks figuratively probably literally
how about voter id tell you who's voting
what's wrong with that definitely makes
an election less transparent but the
left calls it voter suppression yet i've
never met someone who doesn't have an id
well if you don't include the 230
illegals who just moved into my town in
the middle of the night
speaking of check out this new leaked
video that shows what we already knew
that in darkness the feds secretly flew
illegal immigrants from the border to
communities also kept in the dark about
these trips the tape shows local police
confused and surprised by flights
landing after the airport closed in
breach of security they're both
literally and figuratively being kept in
the dark
you're on a secure facility here and and
we don't really know anything we're in
charge of security
so that's hence where we're having a
problem here
so yeah we're hanging out here on the
tarmac like that
i don't know anybody pick up uh i
usually take a basketball team that had
more security yeah 100 percent yeah yeah
and very easily you know
few people could just go
that way yep apparently this flight was
just one of many that moved migrants
from places like macau and el paso and
houston it's a pleasant flight for these
mystery passengers meanwhile the rest of
us get masked and groped like we're at a
halloween sex party
not that i mind it's been a while and
then suddenly the flight stopped when
the public found out so what do these
examples have in common
well they are deliberately murky it's
not that they're just lying they're
simply making it harder to see what's
going on
it's like the dirty lens on my balcony
telescope you know when i'm looking into
the apartments across the way
hoping to see a hot couple making a
panini naked
it sucks
every single thing mentioned remains
cloudy in order to hide corruption
incompetence and worse hard left
ideology in politics they say sunlight
is the best disinfectant but to the
biden administration sunlight has the
same effect as it does on vampires if
they don't take cover from it quickly
they will die
biden's opaqueness preserves him as an
empty vessel ready for filling the
contents provided by activists bent on
the radical remake and so everything has
to be done out of sight it's the
opposite of magic it's not now you see
it now you don't it's you don't see it
now you do and there's nothing you can
do about it now watch me pull these
illegals out of a van
you can't just wave a wand however and
make problems disappear or can you
uh all this paperwork i wish it would
disappear forever
[Music]
magic man
hey
who the hell left all this paperwork for
me this isn't mine
i could see you you're not invisible
i can see you just punched that man
i have a really weird staff
the bottom line
the war these days is between shirts and
skins
non-transparent and the transparent
no wonder all of these clandestine
operators hated trump so much he did
everything out in the open and i mean
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
young man
i missed that but trump's openness
forced them to play along so they just
decided to get rid of him even before
day one
and really that was the only thing
transparent about them
let's welcome tonight's guests
she always lets sleeping dogs lie so she
can take a hundred photos of them for
her instagram america's newsroom
co-anchor and co-host of the five data
burrito
[Music]
he's like a hotel breakfast buffet
served piping hot but gone by the time
you wake up fox and friends first
co-host todd pyro
she's just what the doctor ordered
before they suspended his license fox
news contributor
and
people gravitate towards him as do moons
planets and asteroids my massive
sidekick in the nwh nwa's world champion
television blah blah blah tyrus
[Applause]
i almost lose air during the i lose
consciousness during those introductions
because it's so much dana my job is so
hard you got it rough you got it right
yeah you got it you got an audience and
that's great three people
they all work for me
scared
if they don't clap i will beat them up i
will physically brutalize them dana what
do you make of my brilliant monologue in
which i noticed a reoccurring theme in
everything and that theme is opaqueness
i don't think anybody on television has
ever noticed that before they might not
have i mean this is a very innovative
show and that's why you got to stay up
till 11 pm on east coast time to watch
it every night exactly
there was one other thing that happened
just today what and we've been waiting
for this report for several months
because there was going to be a big
investigation yes into whether these
border patrol
uh
guys agents that ride horses were
whipping migrants remember that yes they
were benched yes they were denigrated
they were told they couldn't work they
were told they were racist right there's
going to be a big investigation well
guess what
report might never come out and the
government said that today yeah so it's
just another example in this and the
media they just they just make it so
much worse for biden i don't think that
that the biden team realizes that the
more the media hides all of this the
worse it is for them right right and the
reason they can't do the report because
it'll embarrass them so it's again
another it's like a second level of
non-transparency but just canceling the
republic if they had just come out and
said
wow did we get that wrong right we had
no i you know i've never left greenwich
connecticut and i'm really sorry that i
had no idea what it's like to be on a
horse yeah please forgive me you know in
a way i think that even the border
patrol agents were like okay fine yeah
but instead what they've done is they've
just tried to walk away from it and the
media is letting them do it of course
because they let everyone every one of
these uh mishaps go todd did they really
think that we would never find out about
these immigrant these immigrant uh uh
flights i mean doing it at the dead of
night it's kind of insulting i mean
you're the only person up right
literally i'm the only human in america
yes why did you why didn't you break
this i should have been there yeah i
should have been there you know what you
weren't fox and friends first you were
fox and friends last ouch ouch
you know that hurts great um but to your
question greg yes no they didn't think
they'd get caught yeah they never think
that they're going to get caught did
hunter think he'd get caught did anybody
in that sphere and it's not just the
biden administration it's the entire
democrat political machine they do
things and either one they don't think
they're going to get caught or two they
think the american people are too stupid
or three that the media is going to
cover up for them and quite frankly all
three have been happening for so much of
our lifetime and as a result we're in
the situation that we're in and it's not
good why what's your point data why is
nobody else talking about this this is a
really big deal people being dropped off
in your community yet nobody's talking
about it yeah exactly there's like now
almost i think according to the i'm
considered the source the republican
party i got the little email half a
million got a ways that's what they call
them got aways they're here they get
they got away and i do believe like the
pro almost all of them are law abiding
but i think you got to just know who
these people are tyrus why the
opaqueness do you you live a very
transparent transparent life you tell
everybody what's going on here i don't
tell him by anything you do
you're you're always telling on me
always
checking up on me
you know it's funny they used to talk
about draining the swamp yeah the swamp
is deep now and it's just mucked up yeah
i don't know what they thought
they
made their entire
point of being was to expose
everything the previous administration
did it was the white house was a glass
house and everyone had a front row seat
we saw everything we saw how he answered
the phone how he sat in his desk how
what he did first how many papers he
read today and you think you can go back
the american people started watching
politics like people watch sports yeah
and now they're trying to go back to
nothing to see here the wizard of oz we
gotta we gotta count cows and make sure
people have masks on
meanwhile the country is falling apart
and i know somebody was put in charge of
this border situation who what oh what
cat what was that
um it's like second oh the vice
president yes the vice president was put
in charge she was bizarre right was she
called the czar yes of the border
so all they did was go 24 hours but we
can't get i can't get a red eye to get
home out of new york
that would be nice yes but we can't do
that because it's not you know it's
unfair because the security risks and
stuff but apparently if you don't have
uh citizenship it's almost better in
this country you get vaccines trips to
anywhere you want in the country yeah
you get dropped off
yeah they find out where where your
relatives are and i guess they pick a
place where they drop you off and then
the bus takes you there i should be i
wish i knew this happened when i was in
college i would have saved so much money
cat think of all the money you save on
flights if you just go to the border and
then and then tell them that your family
lives in detroit and they might fly you
there although you know and you'd have
you could look well anyway i was going
to say something
don't you kind of like
miss trump where we learned everything
all the time in real time and it was
kind of exhausting that i learned about
stuff that i never thought i would learn
because he would ask these crazy
questions and people would have to
answer them you know people were
certainly paying more attention and
obviously i have a you know different
view on immigration than probably
everyone here oh really yeah i do and
it's i i think it's great i think we
need more of it i think any non-violent
person who wants to contribute to our
economy should be able to do that you're
conflating you're getting two things i
actually agree so does dana you're
conflating
that the idea of you're right i was done
talking
no i'm saying but you said that you
might have a different opinion i'm
saying you don't well okay then then a
lot of people do and a lot of people i'm
not a republican on this issue at all
i'd you know and people will sometimes
you know say to me like well do you want
them all at your house blah blah blah
and i'm like depends on the night you
know but
no
last night my husband was working late i
was so bored i would have had many
migrants over it wow great but the
problem is those poor migrants they they
would leave like everyone does um
because like they were they bragged
about being the most transparent uh
administration in history and
there's nothing it's nothing close to
that when you're doing secret nighttime
flights of thing that's that's not
transparency at all and then it hurts
the people who want to have more legal
immigration it helps it hurts getting to
that result that was that was what i was
going to did me to jump on you about
that what i was trying to say is that
like i really want healthy immigration
but it gets conflated like every time
you get mad about this stuff somebody
goes oh you're racist or you don't want
the you're like oh these are the people
that wash your dishes they go yeah i
want them to wash my dishes except that
we're taking advantage of them and the
border states are getting screwed
they're the border states are dealing
with this problem but new york is
getting older i think i think everyone
who's nonviolent wants to contribute to
the economy.com i don't think there
should be i think though that you can
actually count like if you got engineers
to count how many people you would need
it would be actually like how many do
you need this year how many do you need
next year it's like really easy but we
don't do that
so
i just i just think i just solved the
problem ta-da all right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else